ladies and gentlemen
we lost them
we did not get him we lost him Alec
Baldwin has charges dropped in fatal
onset rust shooting and I I cannot I
can't believe it I mean I can believe it
but like I am trying to express my shock
at that they're gonna it's this Brazen
so apparently they're saying that they
dismissed the charges because new
evidence emerged showing that the gun
could have fired on its own
and uh I just I gotta say you know let's
just let's just read it here they say
charges against Alex Baldwin have been
dropped source is familiar with the
matter said Baldwin 65 have been charged
with two counts of involuntary
manslaughter we are pleased the decision
to dismiss the case against Alec Baldwin
blah blah blah as his lawyers Santa Fe
district attorney declined to comment
his next court appearance in the case
had been set for May 3rd the film's
armor Hannah Gutierrez read was also
charged a gun enhancement charges were
filed in both Baldwin and Goodyear's
read were dropped uh gun enhancement
charges filed in the case against both
Baldwin and Gutierrez were dropped late
February so I guess we could have seen
this coming
her attorneys confirmed that she still
faces charges saying in a statement that
they fully expect at the end of this
process that Hannah will also be
exonerated so it's like I just think
it's kind of funny that Alec Baldwin
gets his charges dropped you know and
he's the one who shot the lady and then
the other lady the armorer still has the
charges and she didn't even hold the gun
pull the trigger she should have thought
of that before she had didn't have her
millionaire lawyers
that is her fault yeah she should have
considered being a millionaire and
having better lawyers well I'm sure she
got the job I'm surprised that you're
surprised to be honest like to me this
was duh I'm like surprised that you
thought there was a chance that he was
going down like doing time well not so
much they would do time but like that
they would slap him on the wrist with
something and at least at least feign
that they actually hold people
accountable for shooting people in the
chest and killing them I think this was
the extent of it it was just this
whatever these charges were right this
was his punishment to go hey this is
scary huh I I actually think he did it
like my opinion of the matter is that he
intentionally murdered this woman
premeditated murder he had he had the
bullets on him everyone's like where do
the bolts go do a documentary about this
like because there was a brand when
Brandon Lee that happened there's like
40 documentaries about it like everyone
thinks that Yakuza was involved
essentially and he like owed them money
and then they you know whatever get
involved with the prop people they got
their inside guy his story that's kind
of what you see as but you see Alec
Baldwin didn't like the girl well so
there's a bunch of different is there
circumstantial evidence one is that he
gave an interview where he he very much
expressed disdain for this woman saying
that she was antagon antagonistic to him
that she was giving him instruction she
wasn't supposed to be giving because
she's not a director she hates that
coming out yeah it sounds like his
daughter right no but for sure everyone
knows he's a hot head and uh he was
talking about how it made him angry and
so then you had crew complaining then
you had wage issues safety issues and
then when she gets shot he claims his
finger wasn't on the trigger and then a
video comes out showing that his finger
actually was okay one thing I will say
is anyone on that set got shot I bet you
that there was evidence of Alec Baldwin
hating them and yelling at them at their
point legitimately they could have been
like the the seventh ads from the
cooking guy and then they go oh yeah
there's Alec ball here's a video of Alec
Baldwin yelling at him in the Janitor's
Closet
is there like a precedent there if they
say that he goes who knows who fired the
gun and like couldn't anybody use that
in the future be like I don't know
what does that mean you'll see what I
had read I don't think I have it in this
ABC news story but that they said that
the gun could have fired without him
doing it so they're dropping the charges
but like why would they sell the charges
against the lady but I think the
important details The Last Detail to
come out was that they found live
ammunition in his in his gun belt yeah
so everyone's wondering like how did
this this real bullet get in this prop
gun and then it's like well Alec Baldwin
had the bullets so it's kind of like a
guy Robs a Bank wearing a mask that
looks like a clown and then you find
Alec Baldwin holding the mask and you're
like wonder where he got the mask from
like so he had the bullets before they
they they took his gun belt and found
bullets in his gun belt minus one but
that's a pro I don't know about minus
one yeah
but like they were like I think there
were five live bullets found and two of
them were in his gun belt I think if he
had premeditated he would have had one
live bullet and no other evidence
because they're having all those other
bullets on them just seems like so
either this is nothing or first degree
murder this is like if he literally
brought it
and it could be that they didn't think
they could get him on murder charges
because they're very very hard to prove
so they were like we just let them does
this mean that um Helena Hutchins
husband wanted to drop the case or is
this like the federal government the
government is like we just can't can't
bring I mean I I worked on a movie where
I actually had to shoot somebody and I
can tell you they're like they're just
like here like I never checked I took
their the armorer's word for it that
this is not live ammunition you were
sort of a diva though they were like
picked up uh put it in my hand please
excuse me assistant I'm drooling so did
they they opened the gun and you looked
and they were like these are dummy
rounds and you're like okay oh no it was
um it was like uh you know I'm not a gun
guy but like you know no it wasn't like
a revolver but no this guy's hands he
goes this is a cold gun and he goes
right when we say action you point at
the guy you can check it out on 2B it's
called Phil City and then uh and just
like shot the guy I don't know and then
the scribs went off and all that stuff
but I took his word for it that there
was not live rounds like I don't inspect
the gun Danny kept winking at the guy
and the guy's like stop wink no it
actually is going loud and clear but
you're supposed to check the gun correct
I mean this one I mean this is an
independent Canadian film I don't know
how it works in America
look people who listen to the show no
guns for the most part it is insane in
my view that someone would hand you a
gun and say don't check it okay okay now
point it at that person and pull the
trigger I literally did that that's
insane think about
murder somebody in that case like if
someone really wanted the Selena
Hutchins dead then if it really wasn't
Alec Baldwin it did it they'd be like
here Alec here's a gun don't check it
for live ammo now pointed at her and
pull the thread I will say so we're like
she because she was the cinematographer
I believe right she probably had like
hey there's like 10 people there right
like the fact that he pointed at her
like if it was an ad you know if you're
saying someone wanted to kill her yeah
well they're saying it was supposed to
be like he was pointing at the camera or
something but the bullet went through
her chest and then into another guy okay
so if you want to like let's say break a
window in your movie like in America
it's like okay you need 14 more guys
that you have to handle like you know
what I mean hey this person's gonna be
on the horse okay now we need nine horse
guys
regulation for all this stuff is like
pretty wild so that's why it's not just
like oh some we just hire some gun
person off Craigslist it's like a whole
thing well I think that's what they were
doing actually because their budget now
their budget was really low really yeah
I just mean if it's like uh uh sag like
there's just crazy regulations around
that stuff the thing is Donald Trump is
they're trying to put him in jail
because he filed his paperwork
improperly
yeah Alec Baldwin killed a lady yeah
like he killed he brought a gun at her
and shot her and she died yeah really
and like Donald Trump is gonna go to
jail and probably paid some hush money
to some girls too yeah we have both yeah
I wonder how many and his wife is not
actually from Spain that's the one that
gets me
but I think that's why the real Smoking
Gun I think that that exemplifies
exactly I know Alec bald is not a silver
bullet guy he's more of a bud like
he probably is
but yeah that's the the the
um
I think the reason people care so much
about the Alec Baldwin thing is because
we're currently watching say you know
you've got the feds you've got New York
and Georgia going after Donald Trump all
for these weird nebulous charges like
you uh paid a lawyer and then when you
wrote down what the payment was for you
put Legal Services instead of paying a
hooker or something you're gonna go to
jail for that and a New York jury's
probably going to convict him meanwhile
Alec Baldwin pointed a gun at a woman
pulled the trigger and shot her and uh
she died it's such an example of if if
the world likes you you get to I guess
there's no political motive without it
no but we don't like Alex not like you
the greatest Trump impersonator
liberal sketch comedy show for five
years was just held in jail with no no
charge it was in Romania of course
that's because they didn't like them if
they liked him they wouldn't have done
it he was taunting them though saying
the Romania is the most corrupt place
and he was like I love it here all right
we're gonna show you how corrupt it is
you're right it is yeah we're gonna
arrest you but there's a bunch of uh uh
this is this is the perfect example of
if you hate Trump if you're in the
machine you're protected yeah there you
go
that's if but see in your mind there's a
zero percent chance that he didn't like
that this as actually he just someone
whatever happened wasn't him putting a
bullet in the gun like in your mind in
your mind 100 Alec Baldwin put that no
no no I think I just think because maybe
he is let me ask you a question if uh if
you walk in the room and Ian was uh
standing in front of a dead body with a
bullet in their chest and he was holding
a revolver and he had bullets in his
belt and he looks and he goes oh I
pointed at her and pulled the trigger
now she's dead would you be like must
have been an accident well if you can
also say that that guy was paid to give
me that gun and I'm being paid to hold
the gun and we have the whole thing on
camera yeah I think that at the very
least I'd still be like that sounds very
weird sure I mean just think about how
insane it is you could be like you know
if you if let's say your neighbor's
bothering you you'd be like hey you want
to do a job you want to do a movie you
want to do a movie you do a scene for my
YouTube video yeah
get the armor over here we're gonna have
it it's about a marine who's uh fighting
uh aliens aliens okay and so we're just
we need you to film a scene where he
aims a gun directly at you and then
fires it why is it my gun guy why is he
wearing a wife literally
it's like an episode of Law and Order
like that totally like legit right where
they go like oh there will be a movie
made about this yeah I wonder how long
two years
himself he goes I really need the money
no Billy Baldwin takes the role oh
Daniel like one of the really crappy
ones like Daniel Baldwin playing Alec
Baldwin how many Baldwins are there
there's a lot yeah but they're not all
related who's the one that's not related
Adam Adam Baldwin is that who it is yeah
I think so I really I think he's the
cool one that we like Stolen Valor
did we have him on the show before not
yet and then there's a guy from
Backdraft is that Billy Baldwin yeah
that's he's uh he's a real one yeah he's
a real one
True Blood thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time